hi everyone welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others
uh you know i i was thinking i've been
doing these for uh well a couple of
years now um
since the beginning of the pandemic i
don't know that's a that's a um
uh
uh
you know after pandemic time or
something of two years anyway the um uh
i'm happy to answer specific questions
but i'm also
happy to just try and riff and talk
about topics in science and technology
that i might know about and i see we
have a few questions
left over from previous times
okay
let's see
it's a question here
about
the question here
about agriculture
um and asking about cellular automata
and agriculture
well let's see what i can do with that
i mean one of the things that um
uh first thing to say about agriculture
is
it's been pretty successful all in all i
mean there were at different times in
history people were saying oh if there
are lots more people
we won't be able to grow enough food to
feed them all and it's turned out that
that hasn't been the case
and the reason has been that it's people
have realized that it's possible to make
more efficient crops
by breeding crops and so on um and
that it isn't the case that the things
that were the kind of naturally
occurring
uh kind of crops from long long ago are
what we have today i mean i always find
it interesting that everything we have
you know whether it's potatoes apples or
or any of these kinds of things they all
originated in some particular place in
the world i think potatoes in peru i
think apples maybe in kazakhstan places
like that
and it's it's kind of it's kind of
interesting that these things that have
turned out to be really a good fit for
us humans as oh we really want to eat
this stuff
um they they've arisen in different sort
of tiny niches in kind of the biological
ecosystem of the world
it's also
interesting that sometimes you know i
think it's true with apples for instance
that the um
that uh the the way that
that one gets kind of the apple tree
that's going to make good apples is not
by
letting the thing naturally reproduce
but rather by taking a cutting from one
tree basically and saying let's have a
thing that is essentially a clone of
that previous tree and we'll keep uh
cloning that that tree to get the apples
that taste the way we want them to taste
i i think that even a small change in
the genetics of the apple tree leads to
a pretty large change in for example the
taste of the apples which is why you
know there are particular named types of
apples which really are genetically
identical and have been for a long time
and people talk about you know is the uh
people talk about you know heirloom
different kinds of fruits and vegetables
and so on and that has to do in part
with this question of whether you know
where where is the genetics coming from
for these things that we're that we're
eating and so on you know i think it's a
it's a thing where um
when asked the question you know how do
you
uh
how do you optimize
things like
uh crop yields and so on i mean i i i'm
not sure that um
one sees all kinds of technology that
people try to develop to do that and
i've seen over the course of time quite
a number of kind of hoped-for ai type
applications uh i think in in current
times drones have been a pretty big uh
sort of capability uh addition
for you know you send out the drone you
have it go and and study the um
you know check out your field and things
like that
i mean the thing worth realizing is that
you know to know what's happening with a
crop
you can look at it with
your eyes with sort of ordinary visible
light but if you look at it i think
particularly in the infrared if you look
at the heat signature of it um and other
things you can tell a lot more about
whether the plants are growing and
things like that and so for example you
know every day there's satellite imagery
that's produced of the earth that shows
uh all these different places where
crops are being grown and you can kind
of deduce from from uh
those satellite images particularly
outside of the visible range you can
deduce all kinds of things about how
well the crops are growing people who
are interested in kind of trading uh
financially on sort of the success or
not of some crop yield are always
studying those kinds of things to try to
make predictions about you know will
this be a good season for such and such
a kind of crop and such and such a place
and so on
um in terms of
of a
different question
which is when you have a bunch of plants
growing
and you're trying to ask questions like
uh what will be the sort of competition
between these plants locally and so on
so for example let's say you have a
forest and you have two different kinds
of trees
and it can be the case that you have
sort of rules of interaction between
these trees like if one tree is growing
it might suckle the nutrients out of
that area of the soil or if one tree is
growing it might shade all the light for
nearby trees and so on and so there's a
question of how can you make
kind of
a model typically a computational model
of a system like that where you let's
say have two types of trees and you're
asking how do the how do you get
competition between these two types of
trees and and what what kinds of
patterns can you get and one of the
things that's kind of fun is that there
are situations in which you will get
kind of these these sort of variegated
striping patterns and things like this
that you can see from from satellite
imagery and they look bizarrely similar
to the patterns that you see on zebra
stripes and things like this
and and the reason they look bizarrely
similar is because actually the
mechanisms are very much the same they
are sort of mechanisms of things
spreading out diffusing out things sort
of reacting with each other and
inhibiting other things from growing so
it's sort of a general process that
happens in lots of kinds of systems that
when you have growth in one place you
inhibit growth nearby and that produces
certain characteristic patterns of
behavior but it's kind of kind of
striking to see that sort of the pattern
of growth of different kinds of trees in
a forest can look very similar to the
pattern of pigmentation on on a zebra or
something like this
and it's um
i mean this whole idea of kind of things
growing and sort of inhibitions to
growth when things grow kind of the most
classic version of this is snowflakes
when you have a a crystal an ice crystal
that's growing kind of in many cases
what happens in the ice crystal is the
the water molecules line themselves up
and it makes kind of a hexagonal the
water molecules form this at a
microscopic level form this kind of
hexagonal array and the most obvious
thing to have happen would be that you
get kind of a hexagonal shaped crystal
progressively growing laying down layers
of of uh water molecules and the growing
edge of the ice for to make a hexagonal
crystal but in fact snowflakes don't
just make usually simple hexagonal
plates sometimes they do make simple
hexagonal plates but often they make if
you look at a snowflake it has all these
kind of tree-like arms dendritic
snowflakes
and that's that's what makes snow fluffy
for example and uh is that all these
snowflakes aren't just uh flat plates
that would if when in situations where
you do have just flat plates
of of snow crystals um things will tend
to be quite slippery and that's a big
deal if you're trying to predict
avalanches and things like that whether
the snow is slippery or whether it's
fluffy and what makes it fluffy what
makes it fluffy is that when a piece of
water so snowflake forms by starting off
from some tiny seed uh maybe it'll be a
piece of dust maybe it's something else
some tiny little uh little
seed that then starts accumulating ice
um and it can accumulate the ice as it
as it uh you know if it's in a cloud for
example there can be an updraft of air
that's keeping the snowflake sitting in
this
place where there's a whole bunch of
water vapor
the cloud is is sort of made of water
vapor
and it's keeping the the snowflake there
and the snowflake is gradually growing
and the question is how does it grow and
fundamentally what's happening is that
you've got this crystal and it's having
uh water molecules kind of accrete to
the surface of the crystal and as they
as they hit the crystal so to speak they
they freeze they become solid they
attach to the crystal question is how
does that happen and the question would
be do they do it in a very orderly way
where they're just laying down one layer
on top of the next layer and so on to
make this sort of hexagonal plate or do
they do it in different way and what
tends to happen is when a little piece
of water a bunch of water molecules
have attached themselves to the solid
snowflake they release heat when they do
that essentially what's happening is the
water molecules are floating around and
then they get dragged in they get by the
forces that hold the crystal together
they get dragged in by those forces they
lock into the crystal and as they lock
into the crystal the energy that they
had had that was making them kind of
bounce around
in in water vapor that energy has to be
is is released as as heat um because the
the thing it's that that energy of
motion has been taken away by the fact
that the water molecule has been locked
in place in the crystal and so it's
released as as just heating up the
crystal so what tends to happen is when
a when a piece of water molecules of
water attach to the glowing surface of
the crystal they release a certain
amount of of heat just at that place
where they're attached and so what that
means is that that the chance of the
next water molecule attaching there is
going to be lower because the the water
molecule will only attach
when the temperature is low enough that
there's freezing of water and so there's
sort of a local place where things warm
up and it makes it less likely that the
water molecule will attach so that leads
to kind of a phenomenon of growth
inhibition once you've attached water
and
once you've attached a piece of the ice
crystal in one place kind of heats it up
locally and prevents it attaching nearby
so what what what is that going to do
well what that does is you you start in
a particular place the thing will grow a
little sort of knob out where where some
some ice some water molecules attached
but it won't there won't be water
molecules right next to that little knob
and instead they'll tend to be more
water molecules added sort of to the end
of the knob and that keeps on going and
it's it's kind of going out in a in a
sort of a
line from the crystal and then then
there's enough of kind of an area on the
side that you can make another line
coming out and pretty soon you make a
thing that kind of looks a bit like a
tree because it keeps on branching and
that's kind of how the snowflake is is
formed
and what tends to happen i was very
surprised when i discovered this
actually i i had a model for snowflake
growth a long time ago that's just based
on a simple kind of program in which one
just thinks of sort of regions of of ice
crystal and little hexagons and you
start asking how do you in this array of
hexagons how do you add a new hexagon to
correspond to the freezing of more water
and it was very simple model where for
example you just say that at every at
every step you have a series of steps at
every step you just say add something if
there's only one
sort of frozen hexagon next to you
so if there are no frozen hexagons next
to you then you're away from the the
growing crystal nothing happens if there
are more than one uh
hexagon next to you then don't grow
there at the next step only grow where
there's exactly one uh hexagon there and
what that causes to happen is you grow
these arms and then the arms go arms and
then the whole thing kind of trees out
one thing that that model implies is
that after it's treated out for a while
all those arms will end up colliding
with each other and so you'll go from a
snowflake that was originally like this
one hexagon in the middle let's say it
grows a bunch of arms then the arms
crash into each other it turns out that
eventually when the arms have kind of
coalesced you'll form another much
bigger hexagon although that hexagon
will have little holes in it from where
kind of the the arms didn't quite match
up as they collided with each other and
so many years ago i was like okay i
wonder if this actually happens in
snowflakes and yes indeed it does so
that's a an encouraging thing for that
kind of very simple model that's based
on just this phenomenon of growth
inhibition
now
it's uh you know there are these things
like people say no two snowflakes are
like
i don't think this is true what happens
is that as a snowflake grows it goes
through many different kinds of shapes
from a plane hexagon to little arms to
arms with arms on them to very many our
arms to arms to arms it's it's a and
then it goes back to being a hexagonal
shape it has a wide diversity of shapes
so as the snowflake grows the the um uh
it goes through this whole series of
different possible shapes
and
depending on
which which shape it gets to depends on
exactly how long it was going for
and and to some extent on the conditions
that it encountered when it was growing
what was the temperature what was the
humidity how much water vapor was there
in the air and so on and when you get
two snowflakes you know you catch them
on your hand or you catch them on a
piece of fabric where they don't
immediately melt
you'll you'll see these two snowflakes
might be quite different but what
happened is that any given snowflake
will just go through this series of
stages
and the depending on at what stage it
fell out of the cloud and you caught it
you'll see very different shapes but
then two snowflakes that landed nearby
the issue is that those two snowflakes
may have had very different histories
and the reason for that is that there
are currents in the air that the
snowflakes are falling through there
it's not the case that the snowflakes
all fall
straight down like rain or something
they instead fall they they kind of
float in the air and they they wiggle
around and so on and so it tends to be
things like turbulence in the air
the fact that there are sort of these
random patterns of flow in the air that
cause snowflakes even when they started
nearby in the cloud and had kind of the
same growth process those two snowflakes
as a result of the kind of randomness of
the turbulence of the fluid flow in the
air will tend to get separated and so
the snowflakes that arrive on your hand
or whatever will tend to have been
snowflakes that came from very different
places because snowflakes that were
nearby will have been separated and the
ones that that end up nearby will have
come from from very different
very different origins so that's kind of
why you end up with this idea that uh
you know no two snowflakes are alike is
because there's there's sort of this
diversity of shapes and then uh the
actual sort of histories are very much
mixed up by the by the process of the
snowflake falling through the air
now i think um
uh
so it was a a little bit on um
i'm i'm kind of um
led to talk about
uh and we're talking about agriculture
i'm i'm led to talk about
um
a few aspects of that i mean one sort of
interesting is that a lot of modern
statistics
uh which one still calls modern
statistics although it's not so modern
anymore was invented by people who were
trying to do agriculture research
particularly in the 1930s um and i
remember actually when i was growing up
in england there was a famous um
agricultural research station that was
uh near where i lived
and what had been done there is people
had made they got fields they had these
sort of test fields and they would break
the fields up into different squares and
they would plant different crops or they
would use different fertilizers on those
different squares and then the question
was what could you tell about what would
happen what the yield of the crop was
how tall the thing would grow what what
these different features based on these
different things that you would do add
fertilizer you know
put
this or that thing on the ground do this
or that try try out different kinds of
things
and that
uh
this the the origin of kind of uh so so
the thing is that when you do those
kinds of experiments it isn't the case
that it's a precise thing like a sort of
mathematical thing where you just say
you know add this and this and this two
plus three plus four equals some
definite number it's you you you you
know heat the ground up you put this
fertilizer on it you do this you do that
and you know some of the the corn plants
will grow this high and some will grow
that high and this one will do this and
so on there's a there's a whole range of
possible results
and so the question then is for example
let's say you've had two plots and one
of them you put fertilizer a on when you
put fertilizer b on and you're looking
at which one makes the corn plants grow
higher
well
uh you'll see that some corn plants grew
higher in the a
a
uh patch and some grew higher in the b
patch and there's a whole distribution
of heights in the a patch in the b patch
and so there are questions like
if the if you had some number of corn
plants let's say you had 20 corn plants
in each patch
and you saw this or that result in the a
patch versus the b patch is that
significant or not or is it just chance
so you can get some idea of that by
looking at for example
how broad is the distribution of corn
plant heights in patch a
and what will typically happen
is so for example something like that
heights i don't know specifically for
corn i do know for humans
that the distribution of heights in
humans is so-called gaussian or normal
distribution so if you take lots of
humans and you say
uh you know how tall are these humans
and you just say how many humans are
five feet nine tall how many humans are
5 feet 10 tall how many humans are each
of the each of those one-inch bins and
you make a plot a histogram where you
say how many humans are of each of those
heights what you'll find is that the
number of humans of a particular height
and plot that will form this kind of
bell curve distribution where i don't
know what it is in in the modern us what
is it maybe
i think 5859 is kind of the the center
of that distribution for for men at
least
um and um
the uh and so there's this kind of curve
and the peak might be around let's say
five foot nine
and then it will have a certain
distribution so there'll be some people
who are you know four feet ten inches
tall when they're adults there'll be
some people who are six feet five inches
tall those have lower probabilities
they'll be lower down on the spell curve
so
the the um it is it is pretty typical to
find lots of kinds of things which are
distributed according to this kind of
bell curve gaussian distribution
um and uh human height is one of them
human weight is not distributed that way
human
weight follows a log normal distribution
roughly which is a somewhat different
distribution
um one thing one can ask is why is it
common for things to follow this
gaussian or normal distribution
it turns out there's actually a pretty
good reason for that which is let's say
you have
a bunch of things you're you're doing
you're you're working out um
you know you've got you're you're
picking numbers at random
and uh you pick five numbers at random
and then you take the average of those
five numbers and you say what's the
distribution of the average of those
five numbers
turns out if those numbers are sort of
just numbers within a certain range
let's say zero to one or something like
that
and you take
the average of let's say five numbers or
something um you'll find that the
distribution of the average is very
close to a gaussian distribution that's
a general result it doesn't matter what
the distribution of the individual
numbers is when you add them together
and take their average the distribution
of the average is always close to this
gaussian distribution and even five
numbers is enough to get pretty close to
a gaussian distribution typically
it's it's the same kind of thing if if
uh yeah so so
and that phenomenon it's a mathematical
result called the central limit theorem
that says that if you have a bunch of
numbers and they're all distributed in
such a way that for example they're
distributed in a limited range they
can't be one of them can't be infinity
it's got to be let's say between zero
and one um so long as it's in a fixed
range
then if you take enough numbers and you
average them together the distribution
of the averages will always be the
gaussian distribution
and that's uh that's why
because quite a lot of things are sort
of the aggregate of many effects that's
why it's quite common to find gaussian
distributions as uh
as the distribution of things the log
normal distribution that i mentioned
actually is is also something that comes
up quite often because whereas the
ordinary gaussian distribution or normal
distribution comes up by taking the
average of numbers when you add them
together if you have a bunch of numbers
and you multiply them together
and then you take a
geometric mean so you're taking the if
you have n numbers you take the nth root
of the product of those numbers
then the distribution of of those things
follows this log normal distribution so
when it's when sort of things multiplied
together you'll tend to get this log
normal distribution when it's things
added together you'll tend to get a
normal distribution
now so given that you have this normal
distribution it has a certain mean
that's that's sort of the the average in
the middle and it has a certain standard
deviation that's essentially the width
of the distribution that's how
and the one standard deviation
uh is if you go from the mean you go out
one standard deviation
then one of the important results is
that 68
of the kind of of the of the mass of the
distribution is inside the band from
from mean minus one standard deviation
to mean plus one standard deviation so
what that means is that the the um uh if
you if you say oh i'm within one sigma
one standard deviation of the mean
you're saying
that you are no further out than
uh that 68 of the population is within
that range that one sigma range from one
standard deviation below the mean to one
standard deviation above the mean and so
when people say oh that's a three sigma
effect
what they mean is that the effect is
something that the the chance of that
happening is that that is is three
standard deviations away from the mean
and the chance of that happening you can
kind of read off from the gaussian
distribution
what is it it must be down in the
0.2 percent or something like that i'm
not sure for three sigma i should know
but i don't um
the uh
the formula is it's uh e to the minus
x squared is the is the form of this
distribution and uh i certainly can't do
that in my head to work out what um uh
the three sigma let's see it's e to the
minus um
uh that would be
so one standard deviation would be e to
the minus one basically one over
um that's the height of the distribution
one over e is two point seven one eight
so that's about um uh
uh it would that the curve would be down
at one third now what you actually need
to know the total amount within that
that within
one standard deviation um is you need to
know the integral which is the thing
called the error function if
um and
that goes far beyond my ability to to
work these things out in my head but in
any case the point is
that
you'll have this distribution so we're
talking about crops for example and you
you say in patch a
there's a gaussian distribution of
heights and its mean is this and its
standard deviation is that
in and that's what we measure based on
the particular
we we can we can measure the mean and
standard deviation we can guess that
that mean and standard deviation is
distributed according to a normal
distribution and given what we measured
we can deduce
uh something about what that what we
think if it was that distribution what
distribution would it be and then patch
b we would have uh same kind of thing
let's say and then we're asking
questions like is patch a
far enough away from patch b in terms of
the means that we measured to say yes
patch a is more successful than patch b
for example
and you can ask things like what's the
distribution of the differences between
means between two uh gaussian
distributions and that's a i think
called the student t distribution for
example is that or the or the ratio of
the variances which is uh uh the the um
square of the standard deviation and
that's another thing i think it's called
the f ratio distribution so each of
these things is something that sort of
mathematically can get worked out
and
then the question is given that you
actually
you might want to know is fertilizer on
patch a better than the one on patch b
you make these measurements you need to
ask is there a significant effect is it
significant based on the fact that our
20 corn plants you know uh
12 of them were taller than the ones in
the other patch is that a significant
effect
and for that you have to have kind of
some kind of theory of what's going on
you have to have some model that says if
you had an infinite number of corn
plants they would follow this gaussian
distribution and we're sampling from
that and we have this consequence and so
on and it's a it's a it's a it's kind of
a there's a whole sort of uh
development of of of how one thinks
about that that came from the 1930s that
in today's world is very much used in
medical testing for example um as a way
to say you know is this effect
significant if x number of people take
this drug and some percentage of them
get better is that a significant effect
or is that kind of what we would expect
by pure chance based on looking at what
happens in a population which didn't
take the drug and so on
anyway a few a few uh
riffs on um on talking about that
uh
let's see
um
some very technical questions here
um
let's see
this detailed question from
uh
what wadden has
about a book called structure and
interpretation of computer programs
which i think is by uh
hal abelson and jerry sussman maybe uh
both people i know
um although i haven't uh
i haven't seen the second of those
people in quite a while
uh decades um but uh
it's um it's a book that's somewhere on
my shelf along with 8 000 other books
um
it uh
uh
the real
i would say
sort of a question about
computing and programming and
how to think about it and how to learn
about it and so on
and this is something i've certainly
thought quite a bit about
uh there's there's sort of
computers are built in a certain way
they have
uh that their intrinsic operations
instructions and so on
are set up
and have been set up pretty much the
same way for the whole history of
computing which is now about two-thirds
of a century
um the
the question is when you as a human want
to tell your computer what to do
how do you best explain to your computer
what you want it to do how do you best
uh in particular set up a program that
your computer can run that will make it
do the things that you want it to do
and
the kind of
traditional approach of programming
languages
has been the computer has this intrinsic
way of working
let's
try and make that be something where a
human can slightly more conveniently
tell the computer how to do things in
the terms that the computer knows how to
do
i have to say that the thing i've been
trying to do for the last 40 years or so
is to build
what we might call a computational
language different from a programming
language a computational language where
we start from the things that we want to
think about and the ways we think about
things and we find a way to use kind of
the the concepts of computation to kind
of crystallize the things that we think
about
and then it's the job of the implementer
of the language of the computational
language to turn that sort of
crystallized version of our thinking
into something that can actually be run
on the computer and one of the things
that's very helpful about sort of the
computational way of presenting ideas
is that it kind of it provides a
structure that lets one lets one cr that
lets once kind of structure one's
thoughts in an organized way it's it's
very much the same kind of phenomenon
has happened with mathematics and
mathematical notation mathematical
notation as it is today is about 400
years old um things like plus signs and
equal signs and things like that
before that notation existed people had
a pretty hard time expressing things
mathematically they had to use just
words to say you add this to that and
then you multiply it by this and then
you divide it by that and so on and it's
uh you know if you try and write
sentences that explain
uh mathematics they get very clunky very
quickly with mathematical notation one
has kind of a streamlined succinct way
to describe sort of what to describe a
mathematical thought so to speak and the
thing i've been trying to do for the
last 40 years or so
is to build a kind of computational
language that allows one to describe
things one's interested in talking about
in computational terms whether those
things are things about uh
a collection of objects a collection of
numbers whether they're things like a
collection of cities whether they're
things about um uh i don't know
distances between cities whether they're
things about images and asking about uh
kind of um uh you know what what are the
things in this image and so on the
things that one might actually talk
about
in kind of discussing the world we want
to present these in a way that is kind
of represented computationally and where
one can then
have one's computer help one to figure
out what to to to get answers and so on
so the the kind of the the traditional
uh the the kind of the programming
language approaches computers are the
way they are let's try and put a layer
on top of that that kind of tries to let
humans access it to try and say well a
computer
has something where when you execute
instructions on a computer you have a
program counter and you are successfully
executing this instruction then this
instruction and this instruction and
maybe you make a loop and you say now
after you get to this place in the
program go back and redo this
computation and and keep keep computing
again and so for example let's say
you're trying to make a list of of
numbers list of the squares you know
the numbers n
n squared from n equals 1 to 10 or
something
so one way you can do that is to say
let's do it the way a computer would do
it inside which is to say we'll have
some this number n
and n would first be equal to one we set
it equal to one we store one in the
memory location of the computer that is
that corresponds to n
then we evaluate n squared then we go
back and we run the we we tell the
computer no change what's in the memory
location for n add 1 to it make it 2
okay compute n squared now now go back
run go back to the piece of program that
said change the value of n
um and now do the next thing and so that
turns into like an in a language like i
don't know c programming language that
would turn into a loop that says you
know 4 n equals 1
n less than 10
n plus plus and c that's n equals n plus
1
then then you say well what do you do
with that that value of n well you'd
have to have started building up a list
of numbers so you'd have to start off
before you even start that for loop you
have to say something like um you know
array
is has nothing in it and then you have
to as as you get to the nth number you
have to say as you get as n gets to be
seven or something you have to say okay
put the seventh element into that array
append this thing to that array then
when you finish doing the loop you say
okay now give me the the collection
numbers you just generated okay that's
that's something where you're you're
kind of describing what to do at the
level of the raw computer it's got a
program counter it's got the values of
variables stored in memory you're
allocating memory to say how you want to
add things to that list of numbers
things like that
well that's not the way humans think
about it the way humans would think
about it is okay i just want to make a
table of n squared n goes from 1 to 10.
so why not just say that to your
computer you know table n squared
n 1 10.
well turns out you can and that's kind
of the idea of computational language is
just say things the way we as humans
think about them don't pander to the
details of the engineering of how
computers happen to be made
and so that's a a thing which it's it's
kind of funny because people have a
habit of kind of trying to teach
people about computation by saying let's
think about how computers work inside
it would be like saying you know imagine
you're trying to learn to to drive a car
let's
start off on you know day one let's
learn how fuel injection works in an
engine
um this is uh it's kind of a a a
strange feature of kind of the way that
computing evolved because in the early
days of computing you know you go back
50 60 years ago computers were really
expensive things
and it was very important the humans
were cheap you know any kind of oh we're
going to
spend more effort to program this
computer it's like humans cost nothing
the thing that's really expensive is
time running on the computer so you can
you know the humans have to pander to
the computer they have to do all these
things to make sure the computer is as
happy as possible and then they can run
on that computer
but in today's world of course it's the
exact opposite the the computers are you
know con
it's it's easy and cheap to do things on
a computer what's expensive is the human
time uh and the the human effort of
thinking about things and that's the
limiting factor so it's a completely
different situation from the way it was
in the early days of programming but a
lot of what people think about in terms
of programming computer science and so
on is based on that sort of tradition of
make it easy for the computer so to
speak rather than formulate things in a
way that corresponds the way people
think about things and of course the
things that people think about are not
the same things that computers
intrinsically know about people might
talk about colors or they might talk
about some
things about types of animals or
something and those are things which yes
you can represent those computationally
but that's not intrinsically what
computers do you have to have this layer
large layer of computational language to
actually communicate with computers
about things like that that we humans
care about
so
it's um one of the things that is a sort
of a
a question about programming computers
is the sort of the concepts that are
involved in learning to sort of think
about things computationally
so
uh
for example
uh and then there are
so for example one one very simple
concept is
you can have a whole list of numbers and
it's just one thing
and you can let's say you add one to it
well just adds one to all the all the
numbers in that thing or you can you can
kind of treat that whole
thing
as a single as a single thing you're not
not having to say oh it's got all these
elements let me uh you know adjust each
element separately that's a very
elementary kind of idea
but it's an idea that still is feels
advanced when you think about computing
in terms of the way that computers are
intrinsically built now another question
so for example let's say you have that
that thing it's a big long list of
numbers you want to do something to it
add one to it whatever one thing you can
do is have some sort of procedure for
doing it where you say first add one to
the first number then the next number
then the next number the next number the
other thing you can do is say i've just
got this function and this function adds
one to things
now let's apply that function to this
whole list of numbers and oh it will do
that on all these separate numbers
uh that that's and so there's kind of a
distinction sometimes drawn i don't
think it's really that fantastic a
distinction between what one might call
procedural programming and what's
sometimes called functional programming
in the on the book that the person was
asking this mentioned is a book very
much oriented towards functional
programming um
and uh the the the kind of the the
concept is
do you program by sort of saying do this
first do this next
do you know
you break it down into these sort of
individual little pieces or do you say
i'm just going to take this whole
function
and i'm going to do you know the
function f i apply that to my my my uh
what i've got then i function applied
function g to that and i just build up
this series of functions as opposed to
saying sort of inside how do i do the
micro uh sort of uh micro work to put
things together
now i have to say that in my efforts in
um
sort of building computational language
i found that
it's it's sort of a mistake because
sometimes there are there are times when
these different styles of programming
are the natural way one thinks about
things so to say no it's got to be this
way and it can't be any other way it's
sort of a mistake because we humans
think in a variety of different ways and
you kind of have to be able to capture
those and the real challenge in terms of
language design is to have all those
pieces fit together there's actually
another kind of
of sort of different perhaps way to
think about programming that i found
extremely powerful which is what one
might call symbolic or pattern-based
programming um and here's how that works
so you say you build up some structure
it might be this thing it's a
what is a what is that structure it's a
it's a it's a symbolic expression
so often when you talk about computer
languages and things you say
the thing called x
you just sort of type x into your
computer your computer is going to say
what is x i don't know what x is
x doesn't make any sense to me x is it
has to be a number it has to be a string
it has to be something else it has to be
something that is intrinsically known to
the computer
but actually it doesn't it's perfectly
possible to just say
x is just x it's just a symbolic thing x
and as soon as you have this idea that
it can just be a symbolic thing x
that symbolic thing could be something
that represents a city or something that
represents an image
or something that represents all kinds
of different things and but that is is
then just a symbolic thing it isn't
something where you say and i must know
how it is implemented down in the
hardware of the computer so to speak
it's just a symbolic thing now you can
start building up a whole structure with
that you can say
oh i'm going to have um
something that is represents i don't
know a a um
i don't know a collection of um
i i'll say just a collection of cities
just be some list of cities it's just a
symbolic thing that is a list of cities
and uh or let's say another kind of
symbolic thing might be an algebraic
formula something you know x squared
minus 2x divided by
y or something like that that thing
we're not saying what the value of x is
the value of y that's just the symbolic
thing that sits there uh as the kind of
thing you might do algebra on but it's a
it's a thing that isn't something where
this sort of it's it's translated down
into something that the computer
immediately was set up to think about
like like numbers and so on
so you can represent these things just
in a sort of symbolic way another
question is what do you do with these
symbolic objects
well the answer is that that i kind of
came up with like 40 years ago now as
kind of a way to think about these
things is more than 40 years now 43
years ago the um is um
that you just say what is the structure
of this thing it is some symbolic
expression
and that symbolic expression
might be i don't know it might say disk
of
coordinate value comma
radius and so on that that's kind of a
symbolic expression
um
and then there's one operation that you
want to do which is you want to make
transformations
for symbolic expressions that match
certain patterns
so for example let's say that we have a
list
three things
and let's say it could be a literal list
of three things
one two three or it could be a list
where we don't know what the second
element is it's one at the beginning
three at the end and there's anything in
the middle
so like in all from language you would
just represent that list as list one
comma underscore standing for uh we call
that blank comma three and so that thing
one underscore one blank three
that
that that is a pattern that represents a
list starts with one can have anything
in the middle position than three
so now we can say okay let's say we've
got a whole bunch of lists
we could say let's transform that whole
collection of lists with the rule that
says anything that looks like one blank
one anything three
gets transformed to something else
so that's a transformation rule for a
pattern
and we can generalize that a lot so for
example
in you would often think about let's
define a function
in a computer language similar to the
way it's done in mathematics you say
some function f of x
let's say is x squared so that says
whenever you so one way to interpret
that is whenever you see f written down
open bracket let's say
you know some something let's say the
number seven or something like that
f of seven whenever you see f of seven
if you've said that f of x is x squared
what you mean is that f of anything name
it x
is actually supposed to be transformed
to x squared
so like in wolfram language you would
write f of
x blank
equals x squared for example and um so
what does that mean it means whenever
you see a pattern
that has the form f of blank anything
that blank is named x
transform it to x squared so it's giving
this transformation rule for a symbolic
expression
and turns out that's a very powerful way
to do things because it allows you to
deal with data of any structure things
that represent
all kinds of different i don't know
graphs or
audio or whatever else you can represent
any of those kinds of things as a
symbolic expression and then these
transformations that you make on
symbolic expressions can be incredibly
general it doesn't matter whether it's a
piece of graphics whether it's a
some representation of some running
program any of these other kinds of
things you use the exact same apparatus
to be able to deal with it and that's
the sort of the the value of this kind
of idea of symbolic programming and so
pattern matching you just say
whenever you see an expression that
looks like this transform it the one
into one that looks like that that's a
really powerful way to set things up
and sometimes it's convenient and that's
sort of this kind of symbolic
pattern-based programming um that's
that's sort of a core thing in our world
from language system
functional programming it's more like
you define some kind of function and
whatever you feed it it's going to eat
it
so one of the things when i said f of x
blank
colon equals whatever
let's say we wrote f of x blank comma x
blank
that is equal to whatever it's equal to
what does that mean
that means
whenever you see f of something and then
a second copy of the same thing then
transform it but if you see f of
one two for example one and two are not
the same they don't match the same
pattern
it doesn't transform it it doesn't
define a transformation for that
so what happens with this kind of
pattern-based approach
to describing computation and so on is
you say whenever you see something that
looks like this
and it can be a very complicated this
and it can have some sort of holes where
you're filling in
that specific values and so on transform
it this way it's a very powerful way to
do things in the more traditional kind
of functional programming way to do
things you say i have a function and
whatever it's fed it'll always eat it
and do some particular thing to it
um so and there are ways to kind of make
that a little bit more nuanced by
you know
various kinds of types of objects that
you feed it and things like this you can
you can identify uh sort of different
things that you feed to a function as
being of different types like one might
be an integer one might be a string
that's a very uh simple way it's a very
kind of impoverished way to think about
this the right way to think about it i
think is that you're saying you've got
this symbolic expression and it can have
an arbitrary form and whenever it has a
form that
matches this pattern then you do this
transformation and when it doesn't you
don't do this transformation when you're
just dealing with types you say whenever
it happens to be an integer then do this
but but actually you might say well i
really just want it to be transformed if
it's an even integer well that's a hard
thing to represent you basically have to
say well do the transformation anyway
and uh if you find out or do the
evaluate the function anyway and if you
find out it isn't an even integer then
do something different
it's much better more convenient
and the generalizations of that are much
richer when you just say we've got this
arbitrary symbolic expression that we
can specify as being the pattern that
describes what to do
so anyway that that's some uh
so there are these different kind of um
styles of programming now one thing to
say
is
when you see for example pattern-based
programming it's very kind of obvious
what's going on
in most cases
um it like everything there will be sort
of it's very much you hardly have to
explain anything
functional programming there are some
things to explain there's some things
that are a bit
they're ideas once you have the idea you
can really run with it i mean i think
it's kind of a little bit like learning
something like calculus
where there are a certain set of ideas
and once you have um
uh you know once you sort of have that
idea you can
you can really run with the idea so i'll
just describe one idea that sort of a an
idea of functional programming um it's
uh it's implemented in a i would say a
particularly clean way and welcome
language um it's it's the it's the
following thing
so i mentioned you have um
well let's see you you can have
uh
you have
everything in in languages is is a
symbolic expression so for example one
plus two is a symbolic expression what
is it it's the plus function basically
applied to one and two
now that so plus is a is a built-in
function there are like seven thousand
of those in wolfram language uh it's
sort of comparable to the number of
words in a typical human language
um the uh
uh the the but that's a that's a
built-in thing but now you say
okay i'm going to that another function
might be times another function might be
a random integer it might be there are
all kinds of different functions that
you can use there and you just apply
them to their arguments let's say one
and two
okay now a question is what happens if
you just want to sort of create a
function on the fly that you're then
going to throw away is there something
you can put
in the position of that plus
that is what one might call a pure
function
a thing that just represents a function
like let's say it represents the
function that adds 13 to something
how can you make a thing that is kind of
like just a symbolic expression that
represents that function that you can
put into the place where you did have
just the the the
name plus
and have that thing
be
uh be something that adds 13 to things
well in wolfen language that would be
something like you could write it as a
function
you know x comma x plus 13 that thing is
a symbolic expression just say that
thing let's say open brackets one comma
two that that whole thing applied to
arguments one and two
and
so this idea of this sort of big head
for the the function instead of just
being plus or f or something like that
it's a great big symbolic expression
that represents a function to evaluate
that idea sort of a higher order
function idea where you have the notion
that instead of it being a fixed
function like plus or times or something
like that it's this thing you can
construct that is that you can carry
around as a symbolic expression you
could say you know
v equals that thing that represents the
function and then you just put that in
somewhere and it will evaluate itself to
be that function so this idea of uh pure
functions anonymous functions
uh these are also
essentially lambda functions in in
the sort of historical development of
mathematical logic that's what things
like this were called
that idea
is it's a very powerful idea it's very
convenient idea for actually writing
programs when people first see that idea
they're like that's a bizarre abstract
idea when would that ever be useful and
i've noticed that people have to have a
certain amount of experience
in just
writing
writing programs particularly
computational language programs symbolic
computational language programs i have
to have a little experience at least
using symbolic language
to represent things and then after
they've had that experience you finally
show them this idea of pure functions
and
they having had that experience they'll
get that idea and then they'll be
writing pure functions fluently from
that point on but it's an idea and it
takes it takes a bit of kind of a little
bit of of getting used to if you're
first presented with it of you know
guess what you can do this thing where
you abstract away this notion of a
function into this symbolic object that
is then applied to things it's very
bizarre and abstract and hard to
understand
um i should just mention
um
the uh
um
okay all kinds of interesting questions
here and i unfortunately have to go very
soon here but but i should just mention
a little sort of a bit of an irony of of
of sorts this idea of making
transformations for symbolic expressions
this idea that sort of been the the uh
the backbone of of the things i've done
in computational language the last forty
or more years
uh turns out
that idea
is also though i didn't realize it until
after i'd sort of separately invented
these ideas is actually the same idea as
we're using to understand how
fundamental physics works
in fundamental physics instead of a
representation of sort of symbolic
expressions where they're pluses and
times and things we know what they mean
in fundamental physics what we have is
kind of a
well it's a hypograph structure but it's
basically something like a symbolic
expression and we're just saying
whenever you see a little piece of
symbolic expression that looks like this
transform it into that
but instead of it being a symbolic
expression where the pieces of it are
things we intrinsically understand
pluses and times and things like that
the pieces of it are atoms of space
they're things that are absolutely
microscopic pieces of the way our
universe is put together there might be
you know a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion whatever of
these in our universe
and these atoms of space that we might
be calling things like plus and times
when we use them in uh
when we use them as symbolic expressions
in our computational language the
precise analog of that is the things
that are happening in the structure of
physics
but in the case of physics they don't
have names we don't have there's nothing
special you know the the particular
atoms of space that are being created
destroyed created destroyed all around
us all the time they don't have names
there are some sort of perhaps somewhat
bizarrely at the center of black holes
there are places where there's sort of a
single atom of space that is kind of
stuck there and not not updating with
time it's a place where time has stopped
um and i suppose one could give those
names because they're sort of persistent
things in some sense but most of the
time it's kind of the unnamed symbolic
expression thing but it's sort of an
irony at least in my life that you know
having used these things for technology
and for developing computational
language turns out that the exact same
idea is the foundational idea for for
thinking about physics although as i say
strangely and it's just sort of the way
that these things evolve the way i
thought about these things was in terms
of the physics things about graphs and
networks and this and that and the other
i didn't think of it as symbolic
expressions it was only after we
developed a lot of stuff in that
direction that i realized my gosh it's
the same idea as as in the case of of um
of computational language now i have to
say a thing i've been working on
recently has to do with the foundations
of mathematics and that's a place where
these two ideas the sort of physical
physics idea and the computational
language idea they kind of merge in an
interesting way
and we kind of get to understand sort of
what's underneath mathematics just as
we're trying to understand sort of
what's underneath physics
and sort of the the spoiler alert is it
turns out it's the same thing underneath
mathematics as underneath physics and in
some sense what we are when we are
perceiving the physical universe we're
perceiving in a certain way in the way
that we sort of uh we sort of parse out
what counts as moving around in space
what counts as progressing through time
and so on that's something that we take
out of kind of all the stuff that's
happening intrinsically in the universe
and similarly when we do mathematics
turns out there's the same intrinsic
stuff happening but the things we take
out of it as sort of mathematical
observers are different from the things
that we take out of it as observers of
the physical universe
so anyway that that's a that happens to
be the thing that i'm um
uh
interested in right now all right looks
like we have some um
the uh
a lot of interesting topics and
questions but i think they will have to
wait uh
for
next week
but um so well thanks very much for for
joining us and look forward to
talking to you again next week